candace owens has thought a lot about
this she's one of the few people who
talks about it openly she's the host of
candace and we're happy to have her on
tonight kenneth owens thanks so much
for coming on so if you're i don't know
sheila jackson liam you call yourself an
african-american leader
and you're encouraging millions of
foreign nationals to come to the country
you're basically
reducing your own power and the power of
your voters
i mean over like the next 10 years soon
why did someone mention this
oh i mentioned it for the last four
years i i sounded like a broken record i
had been warning black america that this
is what was going to happen if the
democrats assumed power
that our vote was not even going to
become a topic of debate much longer
because they would fly flood in illegal
immigrants and that's exactly what
they're doing tucker
and it's sad to see i mean i didn't have
a crystal ball and i will say this let's
stop calling it a border crisis
i was able to predict this because this
is a border plan
this is what the democrats want to
happen this is why they're not answering
any of the questions that you
have tonight because they want to import
these illegals they see them as their
next
victim voters what i mean when i say
victim voters is that they're going to
implement the same plan
they have executed successfully on black
america for the last six decades
what comes next for these legal
immigrants free stuff
free free free free health care tucker
free hotel rooms more free stuff to make
sure that i the democrat that i want you
to vote for forever stays in power
vote for me and i'll give you more free
stuff and it will keep going on and on
like this
until they wake up and realize that
their lives are not getting better
black americans are just about starting
to wake up to conservative principles
and realizing that their lives have not
gotten better
under democrats uh under democrat
policies and what happens well
it doesn't matter anymore tucker because
now they're importing a new block of
voters and those
voters are hispanic illegal immigrants
that are coming over the border
so i mean if you're so nicely put if
you're maxine waters
you've just completely betrayed the
community you claim to represent
completely how do the i mean are people
starting to figure this out
are her voters trying to figure out wait
a second it's over
exactly well maxine war doesn't care i
mean she lives in a six million dollar
home outside of her own district she's
done
her job this is what she sold out black
america for this is what sheila jackson
sold out black america for al sharpton
jesse jackson
they don't care because they got paid it
was never about black america
these were the puppet masters to make
sure that black americans remained
alleging to a party that does not help
them
man no wonder they want to make you be
quiet candace owens great to see you
tonight thank you